it's the us's 50th the state and one of
the most popular tropical vacation
destinations in the world but how do you
say its name
almost all the local town and street
names are written in an alphabet of only
get this 13 letters most of them will be
a cinch for you ah a e oh hey que la mu
nu b vay o kina so that makes it easy
Hawaii but this little swishy at the end
is actually a letter the same sound that
hides in the middle of uh up oh okay so
it's Hawaii I'll go try that one out
turns out that wasn't quite right as I'm
learning from these islands this gets
said more like ie not so much I should
have known it was too easy the first
time here we go Hawaii when you say it
that way you at least get the hey that's
not too bad reaction alright
practice time so I've learned that if
you go snorkeling in Hawaii you might
spot a Kiki Kiki and if you bring your
underwater camera to this spot in
kailua-kona
you can snap plenty of pics of the state
Fish the humuhumunukunukuapua'a oh and
this breathtaking hike ten miles east of
Honolulu will take you straight up an
old railroad track to the top of Koko
Head and if we pan over here a bit there
there we go
you can catch a glimpse of the suburb
below which gets called Hawaii Kai
Hawaii wait wasn't that Hawaii hold it
which is it whoa irva after checking
back in on the local pronunciation again
it turns out that it's Hawaii or Hawaii
this kind of behavior once earned it the
nickname the vexing Hawaiian way it's a
choice but you guys know about choices
maybe the tomato tomahto situation comes
to mind there's even a name for this
it's called free
variation you say tomato I say tomato
he says Hawaii she says Hawaii I guess
it's just personal preference
not so fast back in 1958 in his paper
social influences on the choice of a
linguistic variant John Fisher tells us
that free variation is just a convenient
term we use for a bunch of
under-the-radar influences on our
pronunciation influences like the way
other females or other males say
something when we're learning a
languages children which could be going
on here too I also noticed that on the
radio here when the DJ speaking faster
Hawaii gets cut even shorter but it's
not all Paul Hana yet the music of the
islands has one more on offer for us in
a study on the different ways Hawaiian
gets pronounced when people speak it
versus when they sing it
Joseph Killa Donaghey of u H Hilo
documents places where a famous musician
actually splits the word in - singing
Hawaii when belting a tune have you been
keeping track so far you came to me with
Hawaii and now I've found you Hawaii and
Hawaii Hawaii and Hawaii and even Hawaii
ok things got a little out of hand here
that's a lot of answers to what started
out as a simple question but whatever
you call this island chain Mahalo for
taking the time to learn with me
you